io sto studiando perché domani ho un verifica
guarda che cioé io sono una bravissima
studentessa senti a proposito ma quel
caffè allora quando lo prendiamo?
sei la cosa più bella che indosso sei
risorsa sei il cielo e sei il mondo
donna instabile sei la mia sfida grazie
grazie questa canzone é per voi
grazie alla formulazione priva di tensioattivi
aggressivi deterge delicatamente ed è
ben tollerato anche nell'uso prolungato
perché non possiamo stare insieme
se é quello che vogliamo
io ti amo tu mi ami e allora perché
tu sei fidanzato?
quando le nostre mani combaciano perfettamente
come due stelle che si incontrano in cielo
qual è il senso della mia vita?
perché alle elementari la mia compagna
di banco mi ha rubato un quaderno? non le avevo fatto niente
mi sposerò mai?
perché abbiamo due mani?
e perché abbiamo due occhi?
che freddoooo che freddooooo
questa si che é vita!
voglio attaccarmi qua tutto il giorno e non staccarmi piú
e muovilo muovilo muovilo muovilo shakera shakera shakera shakera  e uh uh e uh
e dale dale dale fuerte yeah huo
come hai potuto tradirmi così? io ti ho dato
tutta me stessa ti ho aperto il mio
cuore ti ho presentato anche il mio
gatto e tu mi hai lasciato per una
biondina? io vivevo per te ma te ne
renderai conto prima o poi quando mi vedrai mano per la mano con un altro che non
sarai tu! vediamo un po cosa faceva nel
ma chi è questa ti prego guarda come lo
guarda allora sicuro é la sua ex
si seguono ancora? ma stiamo scherzand! amo lui segue ancora la sua
ex cioè si seguono ancora ma cosa
significa secondo te? no scusa?
la sua ex é la sorella del suo
migliore amico dai ma io sono rovinata
cioè ci sarà sempre lei in mezzo ma no
no no no qua bisogna far qualcosa cosa
possiamo fare? non è possibile questa
cosa non è un cappello bianco vero?
com'é possibile che abbia una tetta piú
piccola dell'altra ma tanto oddio sono anormale
che si inizió a sviluppare appunto
dall'immediato dopoguerra fino ai primi
anni cinquanta
praticamente lui già lo sapeva per
quello mi ha scritto
certo perchè l'ha scoperto che ha visto
la storia
no vabbè ho un brufolo enorme amo aspetta
tu continua a raccontarmi io ti ascolto eh